Katrina:  那就把这个拿了
Katrina: Then let's take this one.
Tasha: 算了吧那把这个拿了吧
Tasha: Alright, let's take this one.
Katrina:  好谦让哈哈哈
Katrina: So polite, haha.
Katrina:  还有什么
Katrina: What else?
Tasha: 我们还找
Tasha: We're still looking.
Tasha: 我们还买了个芋
Tasha: We also bought some yam.
Tasha: 魔芋魔芋魔芋啊
Tasha: Konjac, konjac, konjac.
Tasha: 你们有买魔芋吗
Tasha: Did you guys buy konjac?
Lucia: 我们没有吧
Lucia: We didn't, right?
Katrina:  没有那就够了
Katrina: No, then that's enough.
Tasha: 那就行那我把豆腐拿走
Tasha: Alright, I'll take the tofu then.
Katrina:  火锅调料要买蒜吗
Katrina: Do we need to buy garlic for the hot pot seasoning?
Alice: 哦蒜买了
Alice: Oh, we bought garlic.
Alice: 哦蒜有这个
Alice: Oh, we have this garlic.
Jake:拍个照吧
Jake: Let's take a picture.
Alice:有这种蒜
Alice: We have this kind of garlic.
Katrina:  哈哈哈就这么草率
Katrina: Haha, so hasty.
Alice: 露出来了
Alice: It's exposed.
Shure:  我们少个人
Shure: We're missing someone.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where is the person?
Alice:他去放豆腐了
Alice: He went to put the tofu away.
Lucia: 放 嗯
Lucia: Put it away, yeah.
Jake:好等他回来
Jake: Okay, let's wait for him.
Lucia: 哦这个是什么
Lucia: Oh, what is this?
Alice:板栗
Alice: Chestnut.
Lucia: 哎我没有见过这种板栗就是退过皮的
Lucia: Oh, I've never seen this kind of chestnut, the peeled ones.
Shure:  哎萝卜胡萝卜咸萝卜嫩芽子
Shure: Radish, carrot, salted radish, tender sprouts.
Shure:  香椿好韭菜嘞
Shure: Chinese toon, good chives.
Lucia: 哈哈哈观察一下观察一下
Lucia: Haha, just observing, just observing.
Shure:  变异性了
Shure: It's mutated.
Lucia: 好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
Alice:这还卧了个蛋呢
Alice: And it laid an egg.
Jake: 咱重建一下
Jake: Let's rebuild it.
Jake: 让他重建一下
Jake: Let him rebuild it.
Lucia: 好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
Shure:  青椒哎
Shure: Green pepper.
Alice: 这还是个公的
Alice: And it's a male.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 公的哈哈哈
Lucia: A male, hahaha.
Lucia: 发现盲点
Lucia: Found a blind spot.
Jake:哈哈哈揣俩蛋
Jake: Hahaha, carrying two eggs.
Katrina: 来吧一起
Katrina: Come on, together.
Tasha: 这家店没有了
Tasha: This store is gone.
Alice: 荔浦鱼头
Alice: Lipu fish head.
Tasha: 这家店没有
Tasha: This store doesn't have it.
Tasha: 另一家店有
Tasha: Another store does.
Katrina:  有什么
Katrina: What do they have?
Alice: 在哪说
Alice: Where did they say?
Tasha: 说很近
Tasha: They said it's close.
Tasha: 另外一家很近
Tasha: Another store is close by.
Lucia: 啊对我们我们刚才我来放
Lucia: Oh yeah, we just, I put it there.
Alice: 他能调货吗
Alice: Can they transfer the goods?
Lucia: 我们刚才找到了保鲜膜
Lucia: We just found the plastic wrap.
Jake:拍拍拍个照拍个照拍个照吧
Jake: Take a picture, take a picture, take a picture.
Tasha: 他调不了
Tasha: They can't transfer it.
Lucia: 他一起吗
Lucia: Is he together?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 他是真的吗
Tasha: Is he real?
Lucia: 他假的
Alice: He's fake.
Jake:来拍照了
Jake: Come take a picture.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 为什么要跟一只鸡合照
Tasha: Why take a picture with a chicken?
Lucia: 这是顺手的哈哈哈哈
Lucia: It's convenient, hahaha.
Jake:因为看到了
Jake: Because we saw it.
Alice:这是下蛋公鸡
Alice: This is a laying rooster.
Shure: 下蛋公鸡
Shure: A laying rooster.
Shure:  公鸡下蛋
Shure: A rooster that lays eggs.
Shure: 公鸡中的战斗机
Shure: The fighter jet of roosters.
Lucia: 出现
Lucia: It's appearing.
Shure:  行大家的表情一样的僵硬
Shure: Everyone's expression is equally stiff.
Shure:  我就哈哈哈放心了
Shure: I just laughed and felt relieved.
Lucia: 呵哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure:  哈哈哈像
Shure: Hahaha, right.
Jake:相对民众
Jake: Compared to the public.
Lucia: 这好像是个动图吧
Lucia: This looks like a GIF, right?
Lucia: 是动图吧
Lucia: It's a GIF, right?
Shure:  我们原来那个我们办公室拍照
Shure: We used to take photos in our office.
Lucia: 啊是动图
Lucia: Ah, it is a GIF.
Shure:  然后有一个是原来当过idol的那种
Shure: And one of the guys used to be an idol.
Shure:  嗯然后就
Shure: Yeah, so...
Shure:  他跟我们就感觉不是一个涂层的
Shure: He just felt like he was on a different level from us.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Shure:  就人家那个表情管理和装造我靠
Shure: His expression management and styling, wow.
Alice:超能
Alice: Super skilled.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 呃有个音效你去听一下
Tasha: Uh, there's a sound effect, go listen to it.
Lucia: 没有音效是他模仿的
Lucia: There's no sound effect, he was mimicking it.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Tasha: 你给每个人都看一眼
Tasha: Show it to everyone.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后我们去买保鲜膜
Tasha: Hahaha, and then let's go buy some cling film.
Katrina: 弹舌吗
Katrina: Tongue twister?
Alice:你去学俄语吧
Alice: You should learn Russian.
Tasha: 买个羽绒吧
Tasha: Buy a down jacket.
Katrina: 我不会
Katrina: I can't do it.
Tasha: 还有个薄荷
Tasha: And some mint.
Tasha: 不一定能买的到
Tasha: Might not be able to find it.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: And that's it.
Shure:  我原来也不会
Shure: I couldn't do it before either.
Shure:  我记得有一天滑个滑板
Shure: I remember one day I was skateboarding.
Tasha:奶粉也不一定
Tasha: Baby formula might not be available either.
Shure:  然后一下就会了
Shure: Then suddenly, I could do it.
Jake:再拍一次管理一下
Jake: Let's take another shot, manage it.
Jake: 能管理的了吗
Jake: Can you manage it?
Shure:  管理不了
Shure: Can't manage it.
Lucia: 管理一下管理一下
Lucia: Manage it, manage it.
Jake: 管理一下好
Jake: Manage it, okay.
Shure:  怎么怎么管理一下
Shure: How do you manage it?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: No idea.
Shure:  就是看着像正常人类一点
Katrina: 禁止禁止 10秒钟
Katrina: Stop, stop, 10 seconds.
Jake: 那很难那很难
Jake: That's tough, that's tough.
Jake: 这回来个10秒的
Jake: Let's do 10 seconds this time.
Shure:  10秒
Shure: 10 seconds.
Katrina:  10秒他保持不了10秒进去
Katrina: He can't hold it for 10 seconds, go on.
Jake: 那就酝酿一会
Jake: Then let's prepare a bit.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Jake: 你的音效声音
Jake: Your sound effects.
Lucia: 看大家的管理成果
Lucia: Look at everyone's management results.
Tasha: 表情管理成果吗
Tasha: Expression management results, you mean?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's take a look.
Katrina:  可以无所谓
Katrina: Whatever, it's fine.
Alice: 鸦雀无声
Alice: Dead silence.
Lucia: 鸦雀无声
Lucia: Dead silence.
Jake:没事
Jake: No worries.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Katrina:  还缺啥吗
Katrina: Anything else missing?
Tasha: 还缺保鲜膜
Tasha: Still need cling wrap.
Tasha: 你们买一下
Tasha: You guys buy it.
Katrina: 买了
Katrina: Got it.
Lucia: 买了我们买了保鲜膜
Lucia: Got it, we got the cling wrap.
Lucia: 保鲜膜买了
Lucia: Cling wrap bought.
Lucia: 找到了
Lucia: Found it.
Tasha: 还有什么
Tasha: Anything else?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart shells.
Alice:荔浦芋头
Alice: Lipu taro.
Tasha: 芋头没有
Tasha: No taro.
Shure:  杨老板头大了
Shure: Jake's head is big now.
Alice:没了
Alice: None.
Tasha: 薄荷买了吗
Tasha: Did you get the mint?
Katrina:  没有买薄荷哎
Katrina: Didn't buy the mint.
Alice: 没有薄荷可能
Alice: Maybe no mint.
Lucia: 没看到
Lucia: Didn't see it.
Tasha: 是没有薄荷
Tasha: No mint.
Jake:没有这些都很便宜听起来
Jake: All these things sound cheap.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure:  知道什么叫聚沙成塔
Shure: Do you know what "gathering sand to form a tower" means?
Shure:  压死骆驼的最后一根稻草吗
Shure: The last straw that broke the camel's back?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart shells.
Katrina: 薄荷蛋挞皮薄荷
Katrina: Mint tart crust, mint.
Jake: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Jake: The last tart crust.
Lucia: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Lucia: The last tart crust.
Alice: 实在没有薄荷
Alice: We really don't have any mint.
Alice:要不然下楼摘点叶子吧
Alice: How about we go downstairs and pick some leaves?
Shure:  咱们去那个那什么
Shure: Let's go to that place...
Shure:  买一盆新的就行
Shure: and just buy a new pot.
Alice: 把我们那花剪点当装饰
Alice: Let's cut some of our flowers for decoration.
Jake: 能带我起来吗
Jake: Can you help me get up?
Lucia: 啊小心小心
Lucia: Ah, careful, careful.
Lucia: 这些非工作人员请勿触碰
Lucia: Non-staff members, please do not touch.
Lucia: 小心危险
Lucia: Be careful, it's dangerous.
Katrina: 老北京豆汁
Katrina: Old Beijing soy milk.
Lucia: 但实话说
Lucia: But honestly,
Lucia: 我也挺好奇
Lucia: I'm also curious.
Lucia: 他们上面那个Logic chain是干嘛用的
Lucia: What is that Logic chain they have used for?
Lucia: 我们诶这个好可爱
Lucia: Aww, this is so cute.
Lucia: 啊扫描一下
Lucia: Ah, scan this.
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Jake: 从上往下拍会好吗
Jake: Would it look better if we shoot from above?
Lucia: 呃会好一点
Lucia: Uh, it might look better.
Lucia: 一般来说这个角度会显得人脸瘦一点
Lucia: Usually, this angle makes the face look slimmer.
Lucia: 人呐
Lucia: People...
Lucia: 我们可以比个心
Lucia: We can make a heart sign.
Tasha: 超市有蛋挞皮吗蛋挞皮
Tasha: Do supermarkets have tart crusts? Tart crusts?
Jake:哎呦我去哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, haha.
Lucia: 那就等10秒
Lucia: Then wait 10 seconds.
Jake: 可以有点糊啊
Jake: It could be a bit blurry.
Jake:这聚焦怎么聚哪去了
Jake: Where did this focus go?
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Lucia: 谢谢好像有那么一点点糊
Lucia: Thanks, it does seem a little blurry.
Lucia: 但你是清楚的
Lucia: But you're clear.
Tasha: 啊没有那就只
Tasha: Ah, no, then just...
Jake: 聚我头上去了
Jake: It's focused on my head.
Tasha: 能在网上买了
Tasha: You can buy it online.
Jake: 我这个目标太大
Jake: I'm too big a target.
Lucia: 没事说明他这个抓住重点想拍老板
Lucia: It's fine, it means it wants to focus on the boss.
Shure:  现在对了好
Jake: Now it's right, good.
Katrina:  我俩还比心吗
Katrina: Are we still making a heart sign?
Lucia: 啊可以或者
Lucia: Ah, yes, or...
Katrina: 又来哈哈哈
Katrina: Here we go again, hahaha.
Lucia: 又没聚住吗
Lucia: Didn't you hold it together?
Shure: 5秒就行
Shure: 5 seconds is enough.
Alice:x会员好像不是吧
Alice: I don't think X membership is like that.
Katrina:  他俩找蛋挞皮去了吗
Katrina: Did they go looking for tart shells?
Jake: 好要压死我了
Jake: Great, it's going to crush me.
Jake: 难了
Jake: This is hard.
Jake:蛋挞皮
Jake: Tart shells.
Jake: 哦在那
Jake: Oh, over there.
Shure:  哦你们看过人类宇宙探索编辑部吗
Shure: Oh, have you guys seen the "Human Universe Exploration Editorial"?
Katrina: 没看没看过
Katrina: No, haven't seen it.
Lucia: 啊哪里
Lucia: Ah, where?
Katrina: 当然可火了没看
Katrina: Of course, it's super popular, but I haven't seen it.
Shure:  是的
Shure: That's right.
Shure:  一个算是文艺片吧
Shure: It's kind of an art film, I guess.
Katrina:  什么呀薄荷
Katrina: What, mint?
Katrina:  薄荷和那个什么芋泥
Katrina: Mint and that taro thing.
Katrina:  还有那个蛋挞皮都没有
Katrina: And they don't have tart shells either.
Lucia: 啊我知道了
Lucia: Ah, I know now.
Lucia: 这个是用来送打包外卖的
Lucia: This is for packing takeout.
Lucia: 刚才看到一个袋子过去
Lucia: Just saw a bag go by.
Lucia: 我终于知道它是干什么的了
Lucia: I finally know what it's for.
Jake:是的
Jake: That's right.
Katrina:  自己做麻烦吗
Katrina: Is it troublesome to make it yourself?
Tasha: 不麻烦
Tasha: Not troublesome.
Jake:他就是他
Jake: He is just himself.
Jake:走几步很难吗
Jake: Is it so hard to take a few steps?
Alice: 要放淡奶油吧
Alice: We need to add whipping cream, right?
Lucia: 可能是
Lucia: Maybe.
Tasha: 对淡奶油炼乳白砂糖蛋液
Tasha: Yes, whipping cream, condensed milk, white sugar, egg mixture.
Lucia: 给大家造成一种高科技的错觉
Lucia: Gives everyone an illusion of high-tech.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 蛋蛋液就行了
Tasha: Just the egg mixture will do.
Tasha: 还有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: And Want Want milk.
Alice: 蛋挞皮的话那个
Alice: About the tart shells...
Lucia: 但实际上这玩意很像蒸汽朋克时代那种话筒
Lucia: But actually, this thing looks like a steampunk era microphone.
Alice:蛋挞皮能自己做吗蛋挞皮是不是得
Alice: Can you make tart shells yourself? Do you need...
从一楼传到三楼的那种东西
...something to go from the first floor to the third floor?
Alice: 对闪溢的
Alice: Yes, something flashy.
Tasha: 但是我想要
Tasha: But I want...
Tasha: 叫什么奥昆
Tasha: What's it called, O'Kun?
Tasha: 奥昆
Tasha: O'Kun.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 呃精品
Tasha: Uh, it's premium.
Jake:草履虫
Jake: Paramecium.
Lucia: 我就是这么以为的
Lucia: That's what I thought.
Katrina: 就是你对牌子有要求吗
Katrina: So, do you have any requirements for the brand?
Jake: 嗯大细菌
Jake: Hmm, big bacteria.
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart crust.
Jake: 大肠杆菌
Jake: E. coli.
Shure:  对大肠杆菌
Shure: Yes, E. coli.
Shure:  大肠杆菌
Shure: E. coli.
Lucia: 撒了那种
Lucia: Sprinkled that kind of...
Lucia: 就是生日蛋糕上面那种小糖碎的草莓
Lucia: Like those little sugar bits on birthday cakes, but strawberries.
Katrina: 我我我特想抠
Katrina: I, I, I really want to scrape it off.
Jake:啊这甜甜圈
Jake: Ah, this donut.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Jake:吃了一口
Jake: Took a bite.
Katrina: 如果我镶钻了
Katrina: If I had diamonds set...
Tasha: 我也是我我刚做的
Tasha: Me too, I just did it.
Shure:  这后面是一个姜饼人
Shure: There's a gingerbread man in the back.
Shure:  所以就是没有
Shure: So there's none.
Alice:没有只能外卖买了吧
Alice: No, we can only buy it for delivery, right?
Jake:是一个
Jake: It's a...
Shure:  只能外卖买了
Shure: We can only buy it for delivery.
Jake: 猫头鹰啊
Jake: An owl.
Lucia: 姜饼
Lucia: Gingerbread.
Jake:姜饼人
Jake: Gingerbread man.
Tasha: 我们买个旺仔牛奶就走吧
Tasha: Let's buy some Wangzai milk and leave.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where's the person?
Jake:姜饼猫头鹰怎么了
Jake: What's up with the gingerbread owl?
Katrina:  旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Wangzai milk.
Tasha: 旺仔牛奶
Tasha: Wangzai milk.
Tasha: 走,go
Tasha: Let's go.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: And then that's it.
Jake: 好在哪里
Jake: Okay, where is it?
Tasha: 在哪里牛奶区吧
Tasha: Where is it? In the dairy section, maybe?
Katrina: 好像没有逛到旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Seems like we didn't see any Wangzai milk.
Tasha: 他们家不一定有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: They might not have Wangzai milk here.
Katrina:  哎呀对不起
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Alice:哎呦哦没事
Alice: Oh, it's okay.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Shure: 完了追尾了
Shure: Oh no, we had a rear-end collision.
Alice: 因为他们家有自自营的那种牛奶
Alice: Because they have their own dairy.
Lucia: 算了吧那就走吧
Lucia: Forget it, let's go.
Katrina:  也没有吗
Katrina: They don't have it either?
Katrina:  没有就不一样了
Katrina: If they don't have it, it's different.
Alice:对就不一定有旺仔的
Alice: Yeah, they might not have Wangzai.
Katrina:  是不是跟他们有品牌竞争啊
Katrina: Is there brand competition with them?
Katrina: 利益冲突
Katrina: Conflict of interest.
Tasha: 因为他们有那个自营的
Tasha: Because they have their own.
Katrina: 自营嘛对
Katrina: Yeah, their own brand.
Lucia: 所以盒马对标当然是
Lucia: So Hema naturally targets...
Katrina: 全员竞品啊
Katrina: Competing with everyone.
Katrina: 汇源果汁也没有
Katrina: Huiyuan juice is also unavailable.
Tasha: 你是因为镜头在录
Tasha: Are you saying this because the camera is recording?
Katrina: 桃汁也没有
Katrina: Peach juice is unavailable too.
Jake:没有那你为什么要打我
Jake: If it's unavailable, why did you hit me?
Shure: 那种山姆吧我感觉
Shure: Feels like Sam's Club.
Katrina: 自营为什么不出桃汁呢
Katrina: Why don't they produce peach juice themselves?
Lucia: 如果自营有同品类的话会形成竞争而且这样他们可以降低成本
Lucia: If they have their own product line, it creates competition and they can reduce costs.
Jake:就是你打我然后丢了钻石
Jake: So you hit me and lost the diamond.
Lucia: 不管是制造成本还是
Lucia: Whether it's manufacturing costs or...
Katrina:  嗯还有听你讲经济学原理
Katrina: Hmm, listening to you talk about economic principles.
Tasha: 这里有汉堡
Tasha: There's a burger here.
Shure:  好像现在那个美团也在搞
Shure: Looks like Meituan is also doing it.
Shure:  那个小象超市但是他目前都是线上的
Shure: That Xiaoxiang supermarket, but it's currently online only.
Jake:真的可以做哎
Jake: It could actually work.
Tasha: 可以多要做汉堡
Tasha: Can we make more burgers?
Tasha: 芝士芝士芝士皮
Tasha: Cheese, cheese, cheese crust.
Katrina: 啊我刚看到了
Katrina: Ah, I just saw it.
Shure:  而且
Shure: And...
Shure:  咱们那个地方还不在那个小象
Shure: Our place is not in Xiaoxiang's delivery area.
Shure:  超市配送区
Shure: Supermarket delivery area.
Lucia: 如果他能掌控整个供应链的话
Lucia: If they can control the whole supply chain,
Lucia: 就能把成本降到最低
Lucia: they can minimize costs.
Lucia: 但是像京东什么物流这些都是自己做的嘛
Lucia: But like JD, they handle their own logistics.
Jake:听起来也还行吧
Jake: Sounds okay.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 人呢
Tasha: Where is everyone?
Katrina:  咱自己自助吗
Katrina: Are we doing self-service?
Shure:  而且盒马他们那个配送费你满39
Shure: And for Hema, their delivery fee is waived if you spend 39 yuan.
Jake:可以做
Jake: We can do that.
Shure:  他就免配送
Shure: They waive the delivery fee.
Jake:那就做呗
Jake: Then let's do it.
Shure:  就是其实很 方便
Shure: It's actually very convenient.
Katrina: 我们自己扫
Katrina: We scan it ourselves.
Jake:吃
Jake: Eat.
Alice: 他人呢
Alice: Where is he?
Alice:开始结账了吗
Alice: Has he started checking out?
Lucia: 那里有一个取消交易
Lucia: There's a cancel transaction option there.
Tasha: 你想要我帮你打个折吗
Tasha: Do you want me to give you a discount?
Jake: 你有盒马的折吗
Jake: Do you have a Hema discount?
Lucia: 我这个头发怎么老是乱七八糟
Lucia: Why is my hair always such a mess?
Jake:还是什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean by that?
Tasha: 借的会员
Tasha: Borrowed membership.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Yes?
Shure:  到您了
Shure: It's your turn.
Jake: 到已经扫完了
Jake: It's done scanning.
Shure:  没有得先扫会员码
Shure: No, you need to scan the membership code first.
Jake: 哦那我也没有啊
Jake: Oh, but I don't have it.
Alice: 普通会员不就行了吗
Alice: Regular membership is fine, right?
Shure:  不是就必须
Shure: No, you must...
Katrina: 你们谁有会员
Katrina: Does anyone have a membership?
Alice:普通会员就可以了
Alice: Regular membership is fine.
Tasha: 找88会员
Tasha: Find an 88 membership.
Shure:  我来吧
Shure: Let me do it.
Tasha: 行吧
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  88VIP有盒马吗
Katrina: Does 88VIP include Hema?
Tasha: 找88会呃不是88折盒马哦
Tasha: Find the 88 discount for Hema.
Jake: 哦所以你有是吧
Jake: Oh, so you have it?
Tasha: 呃我我呃等一下
Tasha: Uh, I... wait a second.
Jake: 修硕有还是
Jake: Does Shure have it or...
Lucia: 我甚至没有盒马APP
Lucia: I don't even have the Hema app.
Shure:  我有盒马APP
Shure: I have the Hema app.
Jake:我也我也没有我也没有
Jake: I don't have it either, I don't have it either.
Shure:  但我好像卡里没有那么多钱
Shure: But I don't think I have enough money on my card.
Tasha: 对我我还有优惠券
Tasha: Yeah, I still have coupons.
Alice: 你点不到啊
Alice: You can't click on it?
Lucia: 盒马是必须要用APP才能结账的
Lucia: You have to use the app to check out at Hema.
Lucia: 我刚回国的时候跟我爸逛了一趟
Lucia: When I first came back to China, I went there with my dad.
Lucia: 发现只能用APP结账
Lucia: Found out you can only check out with the app.
Lucia: 我就出去了什么也没买
Lucia: So I left without buying anything.
Jake:哈哈哈那你要坐两个拖车的话
Jake: Hahaha, so if you need two carts...
Jake: 然后怎么放回去
Jake: How do you put them back?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 就是因为那天拿的东西其实也不太行
Lucia: Also, the stuff I got that day wasn't great anyway.
Jake:打的东西还行
Jake: What you got was okay.
Shure: 杨老板要不给给你弄一个
Shure: Jake, should I get one for you?
Shure:  好啊支付宝有吧
Shure: Alright, you have Alipay, right?
Jake:好
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 支付宝有啊
Jake: I have Alipay.
Shure:  那支付宝也行
Shure: Then Alipay works too.
Shure:  支付宝里有二维码
Shure: There's a QR code in Alipay.
Jake: 支付宝还是有
Jake: Alipay is still available.
Alice: 我打开APP
Alice: I opened the app.
Alice: 不知道为什么点不了二维码
Alice: Not sure why I can't click the QR code.
Alice: 是不是因为我们开着那个啥的
Alice: Is it because we have that thing on?
Alice: 哦但你一关那个啥不就停那啥了吗
Alice: Oh, but if you turn that thing off, won't it stop that thing?
Alice:把我家地址录上了没关系吧
Alice: Is it okay that I recorded my home address?
Lucia: 他们会处理好像
Lucia: They will handle it, I think.
Tasha: 有有有有
Tasha: Yes, yes, they do.
Jake:对回头会看一眼
Jake: Yeah, we will check it later.
Jake: 那个看一眼这谁的手机
Jake: Hey, whose phone is this?
Katrina: 这谁的手机他的吗
Katrina: Whose phone is this? Is it his?
Jake: 这个压力还是挺大的
Jake: This is quite stressful.
Jake: 把你们的片都看一遍
Jake: Watching all your videos.
Lucia: 交给你们了加油
Lucia: I'll leave it to you guys, good luck.
Katrina: 你用试试
Katrina: You try using it.
Shure: 减20块钱
Shure: Save 20 bucks.
Alice:不过没关系
Alice: But it's fine.
Lucia: 因为我觉得我看手机的时候
Lucia: Because I think when I look at my phone,
Katrina: 这样也可以啊
Katrina: This works too.
Lucia: 肯定会看到我家地址
Lucia: I'll definitely see my home address.
Lucia: 或者之类的类似的东西
Lucia: Or similar things like that.
Tasha: 我一打开APP就默认我家地址
Tasha: When I open the app, it defaults to my home address.
Tasha: 我的外送地址
Tasha: My delivery address.
Lucia: 我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 我今天打开淘宝查材料包的时候也是
Lucia: Today when I opened Taobao to check the materials, it was the same.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Lucia: 辛苦了哈哈
Lucia: Good job, haha
Jake: 确实
Jake: For sure
Jake: 发生了什么
Jake: What happened?
Shure:  没事可以开始了
Shure: It's fine, we can start now.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 我们要不要再拿一个车过来
Lucia: Should we get another car?
Shure:  再拿一个袋吧
Shure: Let's get another bag instead.
Jake: 插个电吧
Jake: Plug it in.
Alice: 我也是吧
Alice: Me too.
Alice: 我能看到
Alice: I can see it.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:咱咱眼睛插个电吧
Jake: Let's plug in our eyes.
Jake:别别最后挂掉了
Jake: No, no, don't let it die.
Jake: 你的电还在吗
Jake: Do you still have battery?
Jake:还有挺好挺好
Jake: Oh, you do, great, great.
Alice:我的电还在
Alice: I still have battery.
Jake: 我们这些东西怎么带走啊
Jake: How are we gonna take all this stuff?
Tasha: 袋子装
Tasha: Put it in bags.
Jake:袋子哦
Jake: Bags, got it.
Lucia: 有种给自己脑机接口一样的感觉
Lucia: Feels like I'm plugging my brain into something.
Shure: 先扫俩袋子然后边扫边装
Shure: Let's scan a couple of bags first, then scan and pack.
Tasha: 就跟自己是个AI机器人给自己充电
Tasha: It's like I'm an AI robot charging myself.
Katrina: 在哪扫袋子
Katrina: Where do we scan the bags?
Jake:给充电对对对电没了
Jake: Yeah, charge it, right, right, no battery.
Tasha: 你怎么可以
Tasha: How can you...
Alice:放你包里吗先
Alice: Put it in your bag first?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 我可熟练了
Jake: I'm really good at this.
Jake: 没有人比我更熟练
Jake: No one's better than me.
Lucia: 在哪拿呀
Lucia: Where do we get it?
Katrina: 哇这积分极爽了
Katrina: Wow, these points are awesome.
Lucia: 哇我去看一下
Lucia: Wow, let me check it out.
Jake:我来帮您来
Jake: Let me help you.
Tasha: 好谢谢你
Tasha: Okay, thank you.
Lucia: 您好这个袋子
Jake: This bag is pretty good.
Lucia: 我们那边自助结账的话也是在这拿吗
Lucia: For self-checkout over there, do we get it here too?
Lucia: 大袋大袋
Lucia: Big bags, big bags.
Lucia: 呃再来一个吧东西有点多
Lucia: Uh, let's get another one, there’s a lot of stuff.
Lucia: 行好
Lucia: Okay, sure.
Lucia: 我们可以把这个袋先扫一下
Lucia: We can scan this bag first.
Lucia: 他说要扫一下然后好吧拿了俩
Lucia: He said to scan it, then okay, took two.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 好哎好了
Tasha: Okay, it's done.
Jake:好了啊
Jake: It's done, huh.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Done.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 就跟打针一样
Tasha: It's like giving an injection.
Jake:哈哈哈他妈他妈
Jake: Hahaha, oh my, oh my.
Lucia: 然后就可以往里走
Lucia: Then we can go inside.
Jake: 好了哈哈
Jake: Done, haha.
Lucia: 怎么感觉好像两个袋也不够
Lucia: Why does it feel like two bags aren't enough?
Tasha: 可以先结账
Tasha: We can pay first.
Tasha: 这个已经优惠10块钱了
Tasha: This already has a 10 yuan discount.
Katrina:  先结一部分是吗
Katrina: Pay part of it first, right?
Tasha: 对然后再扫
Tasha: Yes, then scan again.
Tasha: 然后还有两张券
Tasha: And there are two more coupons.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Okay, okay.
Jake: 他是什么
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 每100每500省10块
Jake: Every 100, every 500 saves 10 yuan?
Tasha: 不是我的红包券好不好
Tasha: No, it's my red envelope coupon, okay?
Tasha: 我在牺牲我自己
Tasha: I'm sacrificing myself here.
Shure:  哈哈哦哦
Shure: Haha, oh, oh.
Jake:哦哦可以感感谢老板捐10块钱
Jake: Oh, oh, thanks, thanks for donating 10 yuan.
Katrina: 那就先付吧
Katrina: Then let's pay first.
Jake: 好这是10块钱捐赠是吧
Jake: Okay, so it's a 10 yuan donation, right?
Jake: 哎这些扫没扫呢
Jake: Hey, are these scanned or not?
Shure:  哎怎么扫
Shure: Hey, how do we scan them?
Jake:应该怎么扫阿里pay吗
Jake: How should we scan, with Alipay?
Lucia: 都是扫过的呢奥那就行
Lucia: They're all scanned, oh, then it's fine.
Shure:  都是扫过的
Shure: They're all scanned.
Lucia: 这个车里的车还没扫呢
Lucia: The ones in this cart aren't scanned yet.
Lucia: 那边应该都扫过了
Lucia: The ones over there should all be scanned.
Lucia: 那这呃这俩袋子也不够好像
Lucia: So, these two bags don't seem enough.
Lucia: 系一下别混一块了
Lucia: Tie them up so they don't get mixed.
Alice:心痛
Alice: Heartbroken.
Lucia: 就没了
Lucia: That's it.
Tasha: 真的能付成功吗可以吧
Tasha: Can we really make the payment successfully?
Tasha: 哦可以的
Tasha: Oh, yes we can.
Lucia: 会不会有点
Lucia: Isn't it a bit...
Lucia: 我们怎么提回去
Katrina: How do we carry it back?
Katrina: 打车就在楼下
Katrina: Let's take a cab, it's just downstairs.
Jake:100刀100新币
Jake: 100 dollars, 100 SGD.
Shure:  100新币对
Shure: 100 SGD, right.
Jake:一车就100新币
Jake: One trip costs 100 SGD.
Shure:  不到100新币
Shure: Less than 100 SGD.
Jake: 我每次一塑料袋100新币
Jake: Every plastic bag costs me 100 SGD.
Shure:  杨老板就是大气
Shure: Jake, you're so generous.
Lucia: 没到一车呢
Lucia: It's not a full load yet.
Lucia: 这边才装了
Lucia: This side is not even packed.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake: 那可能是400金币
Jake: Then maybe it's 400 gold coins.
Jake: 我估计
Jake: I guess.
Tasha: 这个结过账的
Tasha: This one is already paid for.
Lucia: 对这这里也都结了
Lucia: Yeah, this part is also paid for.
Lucia: 这里这里好像还没结吧
Lucia: This part here doesn't seem paid.
Lucia: 这里是还没结的
Lucia: This part hasn't been paid for yet.
Katrina:  放台上没有
Katrina: Put it on the counter.
Katrina:  没有放台上
Katrina: Not on the counter yet.
Alice:这怎么放呢
Alice: How do we put this?
Lucia: 先把这的都挪到这
Lucia: First, move everything here.
Lucia: 也行对对对
Lucia: That's fine, yes, yes.
Jake:再来一个车
Jake: Get another car.
Jake: 我再来一辆车
Jake: I'll get another car.
Jake: 再来一辆车
Jake: Get another car.
Jake:不用用了哦OK好嘞
Jake: No need, oh OK, alright.
Lucia: 就把这个都挪过来然后
Lucia: Just move all of this over and then...
Lucia: 那边装完的放到这个车里
Lucia: Put the packed stuff into this car.
Katrina: 就是没结是吗
Katrina: So, it's not paid, right?
Katrina: 那就交换一下
Katrina: Let's switch it then.
Katrina: 在那边装袋吧
Katrina: Pack the bags over there.
Tasha: 新加坡没有盒马是吗
Tasha: There's no Hema in Singapore, right?
Jake: 应该没有
Jake: I don't think so.
Jake: 我探索的也不多
Jake: I haven't explored much either.
Lucia: 那新加坡那边是什么样的超市
Lucia: What are the supermarkets like in Singapore?
Lucia: 就这种天生纤维的这种
Lucia: You know, the ones with natural fibers.
Katrina: 呀感觉还需要袋子
Katrina: Ah, it feels like we still need a bag.
Lucia: 全食吗
Lucia: Whole Foods?
Jake:不是就是他们有一家fire price
Jake: No, there's a place called FairPrice.
Jake: 应该是政府给了很多补贴的
Jake: I think the government gives a lot of subsidies.
Jake: 哦叫fire price
Jake: Oh, it's called FairPrice.
Jake: 很便宜对对对
Jake: It's very cheap, yeah.
Lucia: 这个线老是让我弄得很奇怪
Lucia: This wire always gets tangled up, it's so weird.
Jake:哎我帮你
Jake: Hey, let me help you.
Jake:要不就是这个放你后面
Jake: How about putting it behind you?
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Lucia: 他有点有点卷住 我把这个拿出来算了
Lucia: It's kind of tangled, I'll just take this out.
Tasha: 结过账了
Tasha: Already paid.
Katrina:  对方台上都是结过账
Katrina: Yeah, everything on the counter is paid for.
Lucia: 给他弄直一点
Lucia: Straighten it out for him.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, right.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 要不然好像我动着动着
Lucia: Otherwise, it feels like I'm getting tangled up.
Lucia: 他就快要把我缠起来了
Lucia: It's like it's going to wrap me up soon.
Katrina: 哈真买了很多饮料
Katrina: Haha, we really bought a lot of drinks.
Jake:这个是久经验证的插电姿势
Jake: This is a time-tested way to plug it in.
Jake:对其实在后面绕过来最好后面贴个胶
Jake: Yeah, it's best to wrap it around the back and stick some tape on.
Lucia: 你是做过多少次这样类似的实验了
Lucia: How many times have you done similar experiments?
Jake: 对这个1月份到的
Jake: Yeah, this arrived in January.
Jake: 我带着这个到处
Jake: I took this everywhere.
Jake: 就看比赛啊
Jake: To watch games and stuff.
Jake: 进城都带着这个东西
Jake: I even took this to town.
Jake: 哦看比赛还可以那
Jake: Oh, it's great for watching games.
Lucia: 那会把比赛整个
Lucia: Can it record the whole game?
Lucia: 记录建模下来吗
Lucia: Like, model the entire game?
Jake: 这个不会
Jake: No, it can't.
Jake:这个不会这个就版权的问题
Jake: No, it can't because of copyright issues.
Jake: 只能扫扫进场的仪式
Jake: It can only scan the entry ceremony.
Tasha: 那
Tasha: So,
Tasha: 那看电影的时候能把电影记下来吗
Tasha: Can it record the whole movie when watching movies?
Alice:这个放别的地
Alice: Put this somewhere else.
Lucia: 那也不行吧
Lucia: That won't work either.
Lucia: 也牵涉版权哦
Lucia: It also involves copyright.
Lucia: 这不就是枪版
Lucia: This is just a bootleg.
Jake: 哈哈哈这就是枪版
Jake: Hahaha, this is a bootleg.
Lucia: 3D枪版给你身临其境的
Lucia: A 3D bootleg gives you an immersive experience.
Jake:这就是枪版
Jake: This is a bootleg.
Lucia: 坐在电影院的体验
Lucia: The experience of sitting in the cinema.
Jake: 哎是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:我带一个这个进去给你打出来
Jake: I'll take one of these in and record it for you.
Alice:放点轻的吧
Alice: Play something light.
Jake:哈哈我就这个装备进电影院
Jake: Haha, I'll go to the cinema with this gear.
Alice:我觉得这个有点够呛了
Alice: I think this is a bit much.
Katrina: 放点小饮料吧
Katrina: Just bring some small drinks.
Lucia: 感觉很酷炫的样子
Lucia: It looks really cool.
Alice:这拖着底抱
Alice: This drags on the ground.
Katrina:  这什么呀
Katrina: What's this?
Shure:  再来一个
Shure: Get another one.
Jake: 感觉两条腿都要断
Jake: Feels like my legs are going to break.
Shure:  再去拿两个袋
Shure: Go get two more bags.
小Lucia: 再来两个袋
Little Lucia: Get two more bags.
Katrina:  要多少钱拿
Katrina: How much does it cost?
Jake: 编辑一下
Jake: Edit it a bit.
Lucia: 矫正视力
Lucia: Correct the vision.
Jake: 我们视力都有问题
Jake: We all have vision problems.
Jake: 就是我们6个人一样的问题
Jake: All six of us have the same issue.
Alice:这个结过了吗
Alice: Is this done?
Jake: 病友
Jake: Fellow patients.
Katrina:  都结过了
Katrina: It's all done.
Jake: 呃对
Jake: Uh, yes.
Alice: 放点放点占位置的
Alice: Put some placeholders.
Lucia: 近视
Lucia: Nearsighted.
Jake: 对呃这是全景
Jake: Yes, uh, this is a panorama.
Lucia: 拍vlog
Lucia: Filming a vlog.
Jake: 博主博主
Jake: Blogger, blogger.
Tasha: 探店的博主
Tasha: Store-exploring blogger.
Jake: 对对6人博主
Jake: Yes, yes, six-person blogger.
Jake: 博主探店
Jake: Store-exploring blogger.
Katrina:  博主能送两个菜吗
Katrina: Can the blogger give us two dishes?
Jake: 对网上见就是好吧
Jake: Yes, see you online.
Jake: 哈哈哈自己开个超市是吧
Jake: Hahaha, opening our own supermarket, right?
Jake: 自己开个盒马
Jake: Let's open our own Hema.
Lucia: 同时探店这个也做美食
Lucia: At the same time, we can explore stores and do food reviews.
Lucia: 哈哈对我们有美食专家
Lucia: Haha, yes, we have a food expert.
Tasha: 哎等一下别再扫了
Tasha: Hey, wait, stop scanning.
Tasha: 还还可以用下一个券呢
Tasha: We can still use the next coupon.
Alice: 还没到500呢
Alice: We're not at 500 yet.
Tasha: 不用到500
Tasha: No need to reach 500.
Alice:那你多少
Alice: Then how much?
Tasha: 满20 哈哈哈
Tasha: Just 20. Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈满20
Lucia: Hahahahaha, just 20.
Jake: 哈哈哈满20满20
Jake: Hahaha, just 20, just 20.
Alice:来最后一个
Alice: Come on, one last one.
Alice:随便拿几个券
Alice: Grab a few coupons.
Tasha: 我不确定满多少
Tasha: I'm not sure how much.
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me check.
Alice: 你先你先把那个满500的那个10块钱用了
Alice: First, use the 10 dollars off when you spend 500.
Jake: 凑到了500
Jake: We reached 500.
Tasha: 满49和满29哎
Tasha: There's a 49 and a 29 one.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 one first.
Tasha: 满29的水果券
Tasha: The 29 one is a fruit coupon.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 one first.
Tasha: 这个是用的什么券
Tasha: What coupon is this?
Shure:  哎差不多差不多
Shure: It's enough, it's enough.
Shure:  无所谓无所谓
Shure: Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
Tasha: 这是水果卷
Tasha: This is a fruit coupon.
Katrina: 要吗
Katrina: Do you want it?
Jake: 他一天能扫这么多
Jake: He can scan so many in one day.
Tasha: 还有一个海鲜券
Tasha: There's also a seafood coupon.
Shure:  给杨老板省了不到一新币
Shure: Saved Jake less than one Singapore dollar.
Alice:有海鲜吗
Alice: Do we have seafood?
流程：不到一新币
Lucia: Less than one Singapore dollar.
Katrina: 海鲜是不是扫完了
Katrina: Is the seafood all scanned?
Alice:我们买海鲜了吗
Alice: Did we buy seafood?
Katrina:  没有买海鲜
Katrina: No, we didn't buy seafood.
Jake: 一新币很重要的
Jake: One Singapore dollar is very important.
Tasha: 那好吧那就扫不完了
Tasha: Okay, then we can't scan it all.
Jake: 一新币可以
Jake: One Singapore dollar can.
Lucia: 虾虾虾滑算海鲜吗
Lucia: Does shrimp paste count as seafood?
Shure:  可口可乐能买吗
Shure: Can we buy Coca-Cola?
Jake: 买不了哈哈哈
Jake: Can't buy it, hahaha.
Tasha: 虾滑算海鲜吗
Tasha: Does shrimp paste count as seafood?
Tasha: 完了那部分被我
Tasha: Oh no, that part got
Tasha: 们扫掉了
Tasha: swept away by us.
Shure:  没事的没事的
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 算了吧
Katrina: Forget it.
Shure:  就这样吧
Shure: Let's just leave it.
Katrina: 买了1,000块钱
Katrina: Bought 1,000 yuan worth.
Jake: 1新币能干嘛呢
Jake: What can you do with 1 SGD?
Katrina:  省十块也没有
Katrina: Not even save 10 bucks.
Tasha: 好吧那扫吧
Tasha: Okay, then scan it.
Katrina:  那就只有这一个券是吗
Katrina: So, there's only this one coupon?
Tasha: 这个是不是扫过了
Tasha: Has this one been scanned?
Alice:我这个扫了吗
Alice: Did I scan this one?
Tasha: 一新币吗能坐公交或许
Tasha: With 1 SGD, maybe you can take a bus.
Jake: 坐不了哈哈
Jake: No, you can't, haha.
Katrina:  这两个扫了
Katrina: These two are scanned.
Katrina: 这个我忘了
Katrina: I forgot this one.
Katrina:  这个午餐肉扫了吗
Katrina: Has this luncheon meat been scanned?
Lucia: 所以在新加坡坐公交要多少钱了
Lucia: So, how much does it cost to take a bus in Singapore?
Alice:这还没扫
Alice: This hasn't been scanned yet.
Jake: 呃得一块七
Jake: Uh, it's about 1.70.
Shure:  哎呀呀呀
Shure: Oh no, no, no.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  你又加了一个
Shure: You added another one again.
Lucia: 那还挺贵的
Lucia: That's quite expensive.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  那什么你刚才不小心加了一个
Shure: You accidentally added one just now.
Katrina:  那个但是他是这个吗
Katrina: But is it this one?
Tasha: 这个吗
Tasha: This one?
Katrina:  他们那边公交路上
Katrina: Their buses
Lucia: 为什么他们那边公交都那么贵
Lucia: Why are their buses so expensive?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  不是不是
Jake: 不知道耶
Jake: I don't know.
Katrina:  这没扫吧
Katrina: This one hasn't been scanned.
Jake: 可能
Jake: Maybe.
Jake: 国内也是两块钱
Jake: It's 2 yuan back home too.
Katrina: 这没扫没扫
Katrina: This one hasn't been scanned.
Jake: 没错没错
Jake: That's right, that's right.
Jake: 这边也是两
Jake: It's 2 here too.
Jake: 那边也两块钱
Jake: Over there it's also two bucks.
Jake: 国内刷支付宝只要这
Jake: Using Alipay back home only needs this.
Alice: 感觉不能再装了
Alice: I don't think we can fit anymore.
Alice:这个装巨多饮料
Alice: This can hold a lot of drinks.
Tasha: 这个扫过了是吧
Tasha: This has been scanned, right?
Alice: 扫过了这都是扫过的
Alice: Scanned, all of these have been scanned.
Katrina:  桌上都是扫过的
Katrina: Everything on the table has been scanned.
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Shure:  不好意思
Shure: My bad.
Tasha: 这个真的还能装沉的吗
Tasha: Can this really hold more?
Tasha: 小瓶子放进去OK
Tasha: Small bottles are okay inside.
Tasha: 主要是这个重量
Tasha: It's mainly the weight.
Tasha: 这里面好像饮料比较多
Tasha: Seems like there are a lot of drinks inside.
Tasha: 别别别压他了别压他了
Tasha: Don't, don't, don't press it down.
Tasha: 好了万一托着底抱托着底抱
Tasha: Alright, hold it from the bottom, hold it from the bottom.
Tasha: 能扎上吗
Tasha: Can it be tied?
Jake: 我来扎我来扎
Jake: I'll tie it, I'll tie it.
Lucia: 这个这把这个拿起来
Lucia: Take this, lift this up.
Lucia: 然后把这个放在这扎
Lucia: Then put this here to tie.
Lucia: 可能好扎一些
Lucia: It might be easier to tie.
Jake: 哎呦进不去
Jake: Oh no, it won't go in.
Shure:  妈呀这个一会
Shure: Oh man, this is...
Lucia: 这个好重
Lucia: This is so heavy.
Katrina: 这水自带的吧
Katrina: Did this water come with it?
Jake: 分两袋吧
Jake: Let's split it into two bags.
Tasha: 分两车吧
Tasha: Let's split it into two carts.
Jake: 再来辆车
Jake: Get another cart.
Jake: 我来开车
Jake: I'll drive.
Jake: 我去开车
Jake: I'll go drive.
Lucia: 这个这个袋子有点太重了
Lucia: This bag is a bit too heavy.
Lucia: 一个可能撑不住
Lucia: One might not hold up.
Tasha: 我感觉应该分散一点吧
Tasha: I think we should spread it out a bit.
Shure: 这撑不住的
Shure: This won't hold up.
Lucia: 对把拿
Lucia: Yeah, take...
Shure:  这个太太那什么了
Shure: This is too much.
Lucia: 拿两瓶饮料重要出来
Lucia: Take out two bottles of drinks.
Lucia: 然后放到这里面可以吗
Lucia: Then put them in here, okay?
Lucia: 这个够重这重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy enough?
Alice:这个倒是不重
Alice: This isn't heavy.
Lucia: 那就把这放要不然的话 咦妈呀sorry
Lucia: Then put this in, otherwise... oh my gosh, sorry.
Shure:  不要把一个鸡蛋装在同一个篮子里哦
Shure: Don't put all your eggs in one basket.
Katrina:  sorry放多个篮子了
Katrina: Sorry, I put them in multiple baskets.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 拿一些这种轻的东西放在这个袋子里
Tasha: Put some of these lighter things in this bag.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Katrina: 这蓝莓好大呀
Katrina: These blueberries are huge!
Alice:盐火锅底料
Alice: Salt hotpot base.
Jake: 车到了
Jake: The car has arrived.
Lucia: 要要不要再拿瓶饮料出来
Lucia: Should we take out another bottle of drink?
Lucia: 那个这个
Lucia: That one, this one.
Lucia: 这个现在重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy now?
Alice: 这个不重
Alice: This isn't heavy.
Lucia: 我们要是还有别的那还得有别的袋子
Lucia: If we have more stuff, we'll need another bag.
Lucia: 那这个就放这里面吧谢谢
Lucia: Then let's put this in here, thanks.
Lucia: 谢谢会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Thanks, is it too heavy?
Tasha: 你不会在思考这个可行性吧
Tasha: Are you considering the feasibility of this?
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: 不可以
Tasha: No way.
Jake: 真的吗问问
Jake: Really? Let's ask.
Jake: 哎呦sorry不好意思不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry, my bad, my bad.
Katrina: OK 啦这水不是的吧
Katrina: It's okay, this water isn't for that, right?
Lucia: 这都是一些怕压的东西现在
Lucia: These are all things that can't be squished now.
Jake: 这能租推车吗
Jake: Can we rent a cart?
Lucia: 这个这个还行估计这个先放这里边
Lucia: This one, this one should be fine. Let's put this here for now.
Jake: 那那好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Lucia: 像草莓鸡蛋这种这种
Lucia: Like strawberries, eggs, stuff like that.
Jake: 那上哪租你知道吗
Jake: Do you know where to rent one?
Alice: 这个可以放这个
Alice: This can go here.
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No idea.
Lucia: 嗯那个
Lucia: Hmm, that...
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 哎这俩是一块的
Lucia: Hey, these two go together.
Alice:对这俩是一块
Alice: Yeah, they go together.
Alice:这是送的
Alice: It's a freebie.
Jake: 他这不行
Jake: This won't work.
Tasha: 有车吗
Tasha: Is there a car?
Tasha: 你摄像头呢
Tasha: Where's your camera?
Shure:  有吧
Shure: I think so.
Jake: 呃换一个
Jake: Uh, let's switch.
Jake: 这个没电了
Jake: This is out of battery.
Jake: 这些先放车里吧
Jake: Let's put these in the car first.
Jake: 头掉了
Jake: The head fell off.
Jake: 哎呀来吧
Jake: Oh, come on.
Katrina: 来吧放这去
Katrina: Come on, put it over here.
Alice:有点记不住
Alice: I can't really remember.
Katrina:  饮料要先放下边吧
Katrina: Should we put the drinks below first?
Alice:算了不强求
Alice: Forget it, let's not force it.
Lucia: 还是一会再放吧
Lucia: Maybe we should wait a bit.
Lucia:
Katrina: 太大了把饮料先垫下边
Katrina: It's too big, let's put the drinks at the bottom first.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Let's just do it this way.
Lucia: 我们还有袋子吗
Lucia: Do we have any more bags?
Lucia: 没有的话应该也能装下
Lucia: If not, it should still fit.
Lucia: 对要不把这个
Lucia: Or we could use this one.
Lucia: 我这底下已经放了一个饮料了
Lucia: I've already placed a drink at the bottom.
Lucia: 还能压吗
Lucia: Can we still press it down?
Shure:  没事你压
Shure: It's fine, just press it.
Katrina: 还有维c
Katrina: There's also some vitamin C.
Lucia: 这个袋子是不是太重了
Lucia: Is this bag too heavy?
Lucia: 这样的话
Lucia: If so...
Katrina:  付钱喽
Katrina: Time to pay!
Shure:  付钱喽
Shure: Time to pay!
Jake: 送的呀
Jake: It's free.
Lucia: 这个放这吧要不
Lucia: Should we put this here?
Alice:付钱喽
Alice: Time to pay!
Jake: 要买
Jake: We need to buy it.
Tasha: 9块钱要买厨房湿巾吗
Tasha: It's 9 yuan, should we buy the kitchen wipes?
Shure:  来拿着
Shure: Here, take it.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Tasha: 因为不是吃火锅吗
Tasha: Because we're having hotpot, right?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  拿着
Shure: Take it.
Jake: 行
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 9块钱好像
Tasha: It's 9 yuan, I think.
Tasha: 啊9.9
Tasha: Oh, 9.9 yuan.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:搁这里面
Alice: Put it in here.
Tasha: 我真的还有这么多钱吗
Tasha: Do I really still have this much money?
Shure:  我相信你是个大富婆
Shure: I believe you're quite wealthy.
Tasha: 你信错了
Tasha: You've got it wrong.
Lucia: 这个这个能放到这吗
Lucia: Can we put this here?
Katrina: 拿着
Katrina: Hold this.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one?
Shure:  鸡蛋放这先
Shure: Put the eggs here first.
Lucia: 先这样吧
Lucia: Let's do it like this first.
Lucia: 然后我们一会可以再看怎么样
Lucia: Then we can check later.
Lucia: 整理一下好
Lucia: Let's tidy up a bit.
Shure:  我天啊
Shure: Oh my!
Lucia: 这还有有包葱
Lucia: There's also a bag of scallions.
Jake: 哼
Jake: Hmph.
Tasha:这结了吗
Tasha: Is this done?
Lucia: 这是蒜
Lucia: This is garlic.
Alice: 这不是葱吗
Alice: Isn't this scallion?
Lucia: 这不是大蒜苗吗
Lucia: Isn't this garlic sprouts?
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Oh no.
Alice:一样的一样的
Alice: Same thing, same thing.
Lucia: 但他长得真的像葱啊
Lucia: But it really looks like scallion.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Shure:  谁不是谁把葱
Shure: Who isn't, who brought the scallion?
Shure:  哎呀哈哈
Shure: Oh, haha.
Lucia: 不是我觉得我觉得
Lucia: I think, I think...
Lucia: 啊不是我觉得他是葱
Lucia: Ah, I think it's scallion.
Tasha: 可以可以买
Tasha: You can buy it.
Lucia: 同志们要不要看一眼
Lucia: Guys, do you want to take a look?
Tasha: 蒜苗就是蒜苗
Tasha: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts.
Lucia: 是不是他贴错了
Shure:  蒜苗就是蒜苗
Shure: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts.
Tasha: 这这是蒜苗呀
Tasha: This is garlic sprouts.
Lucia: 这是蒜苗吗
Lucia: Is this garlic sprouts?
Alice:是是蒜苗
Alice: Yes, it's garlic sprouts.
是蒜这是一个叠被子
It's garlic, this is folding a blanket.
Shure:  完全不是一个味
Shure: Totally different taste.
Tasha: 才买个葱
Tasha: Just buy some scallion.
Katrina: 啊好的
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Alice: 无所谓把它当葱用吧
Alice: Doesn't matter, just use it as scallion.
Alice:也可以
Alice: It's fine.
Shure:  咱俩完全不是一个味啊
Shure: We totally have different tastes.
Tasha: 不是一个味啊
Tasha: Different taste indeed.
Shure:  蒜苗是蒜的味
Shure: Garlic sprouts taste like garlic.
Lucia: 我刚才拿起来突然一看
Lucia: I just picked it up and suddenly looked at it.
Lucia: 这是到底是什么东西
Lucia: What exactly is this?
Shure:  那张那张账单在谁那呢
Shure: Who has that receipt?
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  就两个呀
Katrina: Just two, right?
Shure:  还有一张账单啊
Shure: There's another receipt.
Katrina:  第一个没打是不是
Katrina: The first one wasn't printed, was it?
Tasha: 第一个打了
Tasha: The first one was printed.
Tasha: 谁拿着呢
Tasha: Who has it?
Jake: 我我没拿呀
Jake: I don't have it.
Lucia: 第一个
Lucia: The first one.
Shure:  忘忘塞到哪了
Shure: I forgot where I stuffed it.
Jake: 我可能没拿吧
Jake: Maybe I didn't take it.
Tasha: 我没拿呀
Tasha: I didn't take it.
Jake: 我应该没拿
Jake: I probably didn't take it.
Lucia: 应该就是这个吧
Lucia: It should be this one, right?
Tasha: 我应该没拿呀
Tasha: I probably didn't take it.
Jake: 那可能就是拿了吧
Jake: Then maybe I did take it.
Alice: 这不两条吗
Alice: Aren't there two?
Tasha: 葱要不要再买一个
Tasha: Do we need to buy another green onion?
Jake: 两条吗我去
Jake: Two? I'll go.
Lucia: 哎那怎么又变成两条了
Lucia: Hey, how did it become two?
Lucia: 还有一条
Lucia: There's another one.
Tasha:葱我去拿吧
Tasha: I'll go get the green onion.
Shure: 本来就两条
Shure: There were always two.
Jake: 应该连起来
Jake: They should be together.
Lucia: 本来就两条
Lucia: There were always two.
Alice:哎哎哎去那边葱
Alice: Hey, hey, hey, go over there for the green onion.
Jake: 订一下
Jake: Order it.
Lucia: 小心这也是咱们的
Lucia: Be careful, this is ours too.
Lucia: 结过账的东西要看好
Lucia: Keep an eye on the paid items.
Lucia: 对放进来吧
Lucia: Yes, put it in.
Katrina: 封条
Katrina: Seal.
Jake: 那不多
Jake: That's not much.
Shure:   绶带
Shure: Ribbon.
Alice: 很小
Alice: Very small.
Jake: 呃买二得三
Jake: Uh, buy two get three.
Tasha: 要不这个吧
Tasha: How about this one?
Katrina: 你在英国呆有没有人就是抢
Katrina: When you were in the UK, did anyone ever rob you? 社会问题
Katrina:  有没有人就是抢这个
Katrina: Has anyone ever been robbed?
Katrina: 你有遭遇过抢劫吗
Katrina: Have you ever experienced a robbery?
Alice:多少钱啊
Alice: How much?
Lucia: 嗯我倒是没碰到过
Lucia: Hmm, I haven't encountered it.
Lucia: 不过这种事确实挺多的
Lucia: But this kind of thing does happen a lot.
Katrina:  逛超市这种
Katrina: Like in supermarkets?
Katrina: 会抢吗
Katrina: Do they rob there?
Jake: 总共就两条吧
Jake: There are only two things, right?
Tasha: 我还想要一个绿的
Tasha: I want a green one too.
Lucia: 哦好像有这种事吧但我没有
Lucia: Oh, I think that happens, but I haven't seen it myself.
Lucia: 但我没有目睹过
Lucia: But I haven't witnessed it.
Lucia: 据说有我们可以讨论这个吗
Lucia: I've heard about it, can we discuss this?
Jake: 可以可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure, sure.
Tasha: 嗯买过了
Tasha: Hmm, bought it.
Lucia: 涉嫌什么谈论
Lucia: What are we discussing?
Lucia: 谈论那个
Lucia: Discussing that.
Lucia: 哈哈哈说一些不好的话
Lucia: Haha, saying some bad things.
Alice:好烫啊烫的我
Alice: It's so hot, it's burning me.
Jake: 没关系就这个翻译给他乱翻译一个
Jake: It's okay, just translate it however.
Jake: American is the best
Jake: American is the best.
Alice:结一下吧
Alice: Let's settle up.
Alice:结吧结吧
Alice: Settle up, settle up.
Lucia: 会翻译成这样吗
Lucia: Would it translate like that?
Alice: 这怎么拿回去啊
Alice: How do we take this back?
Katrina:  一人一个
Katrina: One for each person.
Jake: 翻译翻过去就是美国的东西很便宜
Jake: Translate it as "American stuff is very cheap."
Jake: 他是怎么起的我都想知道
Jake: How did he come up with that? I want to know.
Tasha: 他是怎么支付的
Tasha: How did he pay for it?
Jake: 大家喜欢买便宜的东西
Jake: Everyone likes to buy cheap stuff.
Tasha: 呀我就想知道
Tasha: Yeah, I'm curious.
Alice:直接开始结账
Alice: Let's start checking out directly.
Lucia: 大家喜欢花最低的价格买东西
Lucia: Everyone likes to buy things at the lowest price.
Katrina:  你的仓库star还没有老乡鸡多
Katrina: Your warehouse has fewer items than a local chicken place.
Jake: 经济很好
Jake: The economy is doing well.
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake: 让眼镜记一下
Jake: Let the glasses guy note it down.
Shure:  给大家报个菜名吧
Shure: Report the dish names to everyone.
Shure:  眼镜嗯
Shure: Glasses, hmm.
Tasha: 我帮你贴上吗
Jake: 好啊哈哈哈
Jake: 你就你就
Jake: 你就欠这一刀
Jake: 手带现在这个长度很好
Jake: 就这样
Shure:  走吧
Alice:走吧
Shure:  go
Jake: 走
Alice:我的天呐
Tasha: 那芋头还有蛋挞皮
Tasha: 还有刚刚说的薄荷
Jake: 这车能推到哪啊
Tasha: 还有你们那个好像还有两个材料
Shure: 门口
Jake: 门口
Jake: 哪个门口外边
Tasha: 就从网上买的
Alice:什么美文纸
Katrina:  嗯那偏文具类的我上网买
Katrina: Well, for stationery stuff, I usually buy online.
Katrina:  嗯或者是我看看外送有没有
Katrina: Or I can check if delivery is available.
Katrina: 因为我们在设计地球的
Katrina: Because we're designing the Earth...
Katrina: 那个海报啊什么都是肯定上网买的啊
Katrina: The posters and stuff, I definitely buy online.
Katrina:  啊什么东西上网买
Katrina: Like, what stuff to buy online.
Katrina: 感觉会漂亮一点
Katrina: Feels like it would look prettier.
Tasha: 肯定也会在网上买的吧
Tasha: You would definitely buy it online, right?
Tasha: 我觉得啊
Tasha: I think so.
Tasha: 海报什么东西
Tasha: Posters and stuff.
Shure:  你好这车最远能推到哪啊
Shure: Hi, how far can this cart go?
Shure:  就到这就到头了
Shure: This is the furthest it goes.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Tasha: 车不能推到商场门口吗
Tasha: Can't the cart be pushed to the mall entrance?
Alice:我的天呐啊
Alice: Oh my God.
Jake: 能租车
Jake: You can rent a cart.
Lucia: 这叫我们怎么拿出去啊
Lucia: How are we supposed to carry this out?
Shure:  杨老板先把车打上吧
Shure: Jake, start the car first.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 这每感觉每个袋子都挺重的
Lucia: Every bag feels pretty heavy.
Lucia: 咱这能拿出去吗
Jake: 我们就直接打车了
Jake: Let's just take a taxi.
Jake: 不再买点咖啡什么的
Jake: Not going to grab some coffee or something?
Jake: 不了吧
Jake: Nah.
Jake: 现在有点晚了
Jake: It's a bit late now.
Katrina:  我们直接去吃饭是吗
Katrina: Are we going straight to eat?
Jake: 好的
Jake: Yep.
Tasha: 对吃什么呢
Tasha: Yeah, what should we eat?
Shure:  你们拎着这么多东西
Shure: You guys have so much stuff.
Alice: 这地能有放的吗
Alice: Is there a place to put this stuff?
Shure:  东西
Shure: Stuff.
Jake: 确实啊
Jake: True.
Shure: 肯定得回趟家
Shure: We definitely have to go home first.
Lucia: 拿这么多东西去吃饭有点
Lucia: Taking all this stuff to eat is a bit...
Shure:  要不就吃饭
Shure: How about we just eat out?
Tasha: 要不就点外卖吧
Tasha: Or we could order takeout.
Jake: 行回去点外卖吧
Jake: Yeah, let's go home and order takeout.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Lucia: 都可以一起出去也可以
Lucia: We could all go out together too.
Jake: 在这是就是有冻的东西对吧
Jake: But then we have frozen stuff here, right?
Shure:  是吧而且还有要要冻的东西
Shure: Right, and there's stuff that needs to stay frozen.
Jake: 是吧是有冷冻的
Jake: Yeah, there's frozen stuff.
Jake: 冷冻的东西
Jake: Frozen stuff.
Shure:  然后大家看一眼那个哪些是冷冻
Shure: So, let's check which ones need to be frozen.
Lucia: 嗯确实
Lucia: Hmm, true.
Shure:  哪些是冷藏
Shure: And which ones need to be refrigerated.
Katrina:  放一会吧
Katrina: Just leave it for a bit.
Shure:  比如说那毛肚什么的
Shure: Like the tripe, for example.
Shure:  他就是说让0-4度
Shure: It needs to be kept at 0-4 degrees.
Tasha: 你要放下来吗
Tasha: Do you want to put it down?
Jake: 啊再来一辆车你要不
Jake: Should we call another car?
Shure:  他只能到这儿了
Shure: This is as far as it goes.
Tasha: 他只能到这儿了
Tasha: This is as far as it goes.
Shure:  爸爸只能送你到这儿了
Shure: Dad can only take you this far.
Shure:  未来的路要靠你自己了
Shure: The rest of the journey is up to you.
Lucia: 妈耶
Lucia: Oh my god.
Shure:  听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear that?
Shure:  那是你的朗姆的声音
Shure: That was your rum talking.
Shure:  他现在向你发出回应
Shure: It's responding to you now.
Alice:有点沉这个给我吧
Alice: This is a bit heavy, let me take it.
Katrina:  这样我们的冰箱就满了
Katrina: Our fridge will be full like this.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 冰箱能不能放下呀
Lucia: Can the fridge fit it?
Shure:  你不要把它喝凉了
Shure: Don't drink it cold.
Shure:  哈哈哈全喝光
Shure: Haha, drink it all up.
Jake: 回头
Jake: Later
Katrina: 草莓也全吃了
Katrina: Eat all the strawberries too.
Jake: 就是这个数据比较重要
Jake: This data is pretty important.
Jake: 就是回头你们收拾的时候
Jake: When you guys are cleaning up later,
Jake: 会和超市
Jake: you'll have to work with the supermarket.
Jake: 你们的一些行为建立一些联系
Jake: Some of your actions will establish connections.
Jake: 就是比方说你把这东西放到冰箱
Jake: For example, you put this thing in the fridge,
Jake: 然后他只能找回到你在哪找到的那个
Jake: then they can only trace it back to where you found it.
Lucia: 哦那就跟亚马逊那个无人采购超市
Lucia: Oh, it's like that Amazon cashier-less supermarket.
Lucia: 一样的那种感觉
Lucia: That kind of feeling.
Jake: 对对对溯源
Jake: Yes, yes, traceability.
Katrina: 溯源啦
Katrina: Traceability, right.
Jake: 对就是溯源这种rechieve
Jake: Yes, it's this kind of retrieve.
Jake: 特厉害你去不
Jake: It's really amazing, isn't it?
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: So amazing.
Shure:  你们上链的吗
Shure: Are you guys on the blockchain?
Shure:  呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Katrina:  当心哦
Katrina: Be careful.
Katrina:  谢谢阿莫总
Katrina: Thanks, Amos.
Lucia: 阿莫总开了好几个那种
Lucia: Amos has opened several of those,
Lucia: 那种超市
Lucia: those supermarkets.
Lucia: 就是你出门不用结账
Lucia: You don't need to check out when you leave.
Lucia: 他知道你买了什么
Lucia: It knows what you bought.
Lucia: 然后自动在你的账户里付款
Lucia: Then it automatically charges your account.
Lucia: 就是他根据你的重量
Lucia: It goes by your weight,
Lucia: 好像就是你放进去然后东西多重
Lucia: like you put it in and it knows how heavy it is.
Lucia: 对他会精确到多少多少毫克
Lucia: Right, it can be precise down to milligrams.
Lucia: 然后呢他就会自动把这钱扣走
Lucia: Then it automatically deducts the money.
Lucia: 是超市里
Lucia: In the supermarket.
Lucia: 就跟我们一样
Lucia: Just like us.
Jake:那我要稍微哎
Jake: Then I should slightly...
Lucia: 就是它有很多摄像头
Lucia: It has a lot of cameras.
Lucia: 就是能看到你拿了什么
Lucia: They can see what you take.
Lucia: 他监测你有没有在货架上拿东西
Lucia: It monitors if you take anything off the shelves.
Lucia: 包括你进出的时候的各种数据
Lucia: Including all sorts of data when you enter and exit.
Lucia: 反正很神奇的一个东西
Lucia: It's a really amazing thing.
Lucia: 不过就是偶尔有算错的可能性
Lucia: But there's just a chance of occasional miscalculations.
Shure:  那肯定
Shure: That's for sure.
Shure:  因为每一个我都这么拿
Shure: Because I take each one like this.
Lucia: 哎那个好像他也能监测的到
Lucia: Hey, it seems like he can also monitor that.
Lucia: 呵呵不过有时候是会算错的
Lucia: Haha, but sometimes it does miscalculate.
Shure:  我打个雨伞呐
Shure: I'm using an umbrella.
Shure:  他肯定检测不到了吧
Shure: He definitely can't detect that, right?
Lucia: 去实验一下
Lucia: Let's experiment with it.
Jake: 就是这是他的玻璃
Jake: It's just, this is his glass.
Jake:玻璃好歹还在人抢
Jake: At least the glass is still being contested for by people.
Jake: 好歹还算算法错误
Jake: At least it's still considered an algorithm error.
Shure:  就是我就爱打伞
Shure: I just love using an umbrella.
Shure:  在室内
Shure: Indoors.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 他有可能是商品上面贴条了
Jake: Maybe he put a tag on the product.
Jake: 贴无线电
Jake: A radio tag.
Jake: 他还有6分钟到
Jake: He'll be here in six minutes.
Alice:开始往下走吧
Alice: Let's start heading down.
Jake: 往上走好像是
Jake: It seems like we should head up.
Jake:这是往上走对吧
Jake: We should be heading up, right?
Katrina:  往下吧
Katrina: Let's head down.
Alice:我们不是二楼吗
Alice: Aren't we on the second floor?
Alice:我们是这样上来的呀
Alice: We came up this way.
Jake:哦这么回事啊
Jake: Oh, that's how it is.
Alice: 一进门一进门不是有个升的电梯
Alice: As soon as you enter, there's an elevator going up.
Jake: 有道理
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake: 因为这地方太像地下了
Jake: Because this place feels like a basement.
Alice: 有点阴森有点不热闹
Alice: It's a bit eerie, not very lively.
Shure:  我在搞地下音乐
Shure: I'm into underground music.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:有点
Alice: A bit.
Katrina:  这我来吧
Katrina: I'll take this.
Katrina: 因为我有一个鸡蛋
Katrina: Because I have an egg.
Alice: 没事这个不沉
Alice: It's okay, this isn't heavy.
Katrina:  你看
Katrina: Look.
Katrina:  没事我就一点点都没
Katrina: It's fine, I barely have anything.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Tasha: 你你一个人拎两个
Tasha: You, you carry two by yourself.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈那我再放下一个能能能懂吗
Katrina: 就主要是那个酒比较多的那个
Jake: 你你你这么厉害吗
Alice: 而且饮料多的比较沉
Alice: 你再一人掂一掂
Jake: 这才对嘛
Jake: 走吧
Shure:  您是
Katrina: 没事你你
Katrina: 真的可以这样利用老板吗
Shure:  天啊
Jake:这样比较平衡
Shure:  这样比较这厨房湿巾一定很沉吧
Tasha: 哈哈哈这这鸡蛋也很沉吧
Lucia: 哈哈这鸡蛋很宝贵
Shure:  对没事
Katrina:  我需要专人护送
Shure:  我只送到你们到门口
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 我这线是掉了吗
Jake: Did my line disconnect?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No
Tasha: 老板
Tasha: Boss
Tasha: 老板拎着最多的东西
Tasha: Boss is carrying the most stuff
Lucia: 真的真的
Lucia: Really, really
Lucia: 要不要帮你安上
Lucia: Do you want me to help you set it up?
Jake:好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Just a moment
Lucia: 你别走
Lucia: Don't move
Jake: OK了开始开动
Jake: All set, let's start
Katrina: connected
Katrina: Connected
Lucia: 你不要和机器人一样突然充了电的感觉
Lucia: Don't act like a robot that suddenly got charged
Shure:  这是老板吗
Shure: Is that the boss?
Shure:  我们是被一个AI领导的一群人类
Shure: Are we being led by an AI?
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Tasha: 呃重吗我跟你一起拎
Tasha: Is it heavy? I'll help you carry it
Alice:不用不用这个就一个兜啊
Alice: No need, it's just one bag
Jake: 就我我头上的和我眼前的
Jake: Just the one on my head and the one in front of me
Shure: 那个鸡蛋保护起来一定很累
Shure: Protecting that egg must be really tiring
Jake: 就是我的接收设备
Jake: This is my receiving device
Katrina: 不行你没有这个资格
Katrina: No, you don't have the right.
Jake: 我全靠他来支撑我
Jake: I rely on him for support.
Jake: 哈哈哈一些行为
Jake: Haha, some actions.
Lucia: 这个故事开始向恐怖片方向发展了
Lucia: This story is starting to turn into a horror movie.
Tasha: 这颗葱拐到你的脚了
Tasha: This green onion hit your foot.
Tasha: 我帮你拿着
Tasha: Let me hold it for you.
Shure:  你要把鼻也夹进去
Shure: You should squeeze your nose in too.
Jake:啊会吗谢谢
Jake: Oh really? Thanks.
Katrina: 所以他们要
Katrina: So they want to...
Jake: 所以很重要
Jake: So it's important.
Katrina: 所以你们最后买葱了吗
Katrina: So did you guys end up buying green onions?
Jake: 哈哈哈所以呢
Jake: Haha, so what?
Jake:哈哈哈critical
Jake: Haha, critical.
Alice:买了买了
Alice: Yes, we bought it.
Shure:  买了这么大一节葱白
Shure: We bought such a big section of green onions.
Alice:不是这还是蒜苗
Alice: No, this is still garlic sprouts.
Lucia: 啊这对我们是从这边下吗
Lucia: Ah, are we going down from here?
Alice:我们的葱在那个篮里面呢
Alice: Our green onions are in that basket.
Tasha: 买了一个葱姜蒜组合
Tasha: We bought a combination of green onion, ginger, and garlic.
Shure:  发明这个的人真是天才
Shure: The person who invented this is a genius.
Jake: 我觉得每人带根线是有点酷啊
Jake: I think everyone carrying a wire is pretty cool.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Jake:你这么一眼看过去
Jake: When you look at it all at once...
Alice:尤其我们这样走在一起
Alice: Especially when we walk together like this.
Shure: 一会我回程的路上要地铁
Shure: Later, I need to take the subway on my way back.
Alice:感觉像一个什么组织
Alice: Feels like some kind of organization.
Tasha: 有点像一个神秘组织
Tasha: Kind of like a secret organization.
Shure: 这个数据要录下来吗
Shure: Do we need to record this data?
Jake: 可以录
Jake: We can record it.
Shure:  OK
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 尤其这个眼镜还发光的感觉
Tasha: Especially with these glowing glasses.
Katrina: 但他地铁要差不多两个小时
Katrina: But the subway takes almost two hours.
Jake:你地铁你地铁
Jake: Your subway, your subway...
Tasha: 大家都带同一款
Tasha: Everyone is wearing the same style.
Jake: 进个进一下出一下得了
Jake: Just go in and out, that's it.
Jake: 你就进去吧
Jake: Just go in.
Jake: 进去然后就关掉
Jake: Go in and then turn it off.
Jake: 然后主要是你看你答辩
Jake: The main thing is, you see, your defense...
Jake:哈哈哈你答辩
Jake: Haha, your defense.
Shure:  真的真的好录吗
Shure: Really, really, can we record this?
Shure:  方便吗方便哎
Shure: Is it convenient? Convenient, huh.
Jake:方便
Jake: Convenient.
Jake: 你问Andy对吧你的老师Andy
Jake: You asked Andy, right? Your teacher Andy.
Shure:  说我在进行一个奇怪的项目
Shure: Told him I'm doing a weird project.
Jake: 对你问Andy想不想进数据集
Jake: Yes, you asked Andy if he wants to be in the dataset.
Jake: 想不想被人研究研究
Jake: If he wants to be researched.
Shure:  安妮好像英国人会对这
Shure: Annie, being British, might be more sensitive about this.
Shure:  隐私方面更敏感一些吧
Shure: More sensitive about privacy, right?
Lucia: 我们往哪走啊
Lucia: Which way are we going?
Lucia: 是这边吗
Lucia: Is it this way?
Alice: 都可以出去
Alice: We can go either way.
Tasha: 这边是我们刚刚
Tasha: This way is where we just...
Tasha: 最近的那个
Tasha: ...recently...
Katrina:  嗯不不不
Katrina: Uh, no no no.
Alice:这个门这个门
Alice: This door, this door.
Alice:都一样
Alice: It's all the same.
Lucia: yes yes
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jake: 这是探路去了
Jake: They went scouting.
Jake: 这是北京通州案吗
Jake: Is this the Tongzhou case in Beijing?
Shure:  呃也不至于
Shure: Uh, not really.
Katrina:  我觉得也是吧
Katrina: I think so too.
Lucia: 这个应该也能出去吧
Lucia: We should be able to get out from here, right?
Shure:  四五十是不是
Shure: Forty or fifty, right?
Lucia: 我们为什么不从那里出呢
Lucia: Why don't we go out from there?
Jake: 帮我接个电话
Jake: Help me answer the phone.
Katrina: 你放地上吧
Katrina: Just put it down.
Jake: 算了我来
Jake: Never mind, I'll do it.
Shure:  要不我送你们到这我就先溜了
Shure: How about I drop you off here and then I'll leave.
Shure:  走吧再见
Shure: Let's go, bye.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Jake: 哎我想挠头我靠
Jake: Oh, I want to scratch my head, damn.
Katrina:  拜拜明天见
Katrina: Bye-bye, see you tomorrow.
Jake: 喂你好
Jake: Hello, hi.
Shure:  明天见今晚不要想我哦
Shure: See you tomorrow, don't think of me tonight.
Lucia: 明天见
Lucia: See you tomorrow.
Katrina: 希望你答辩顺利哦
Katrina: Hope your defense goes well.
Katrina:  对你就到这了
Katrina: Right, this is as far as you go.
Shure:  对我就到这了
Shure: Yeah, this is it for me.
Shure:  呃所以你不能只拎一包湿巾
Shure: Uh, so you can't just carry one pack of wet wipes.
Jake: 呃呃我找找你吧
Jake: Uh, uh, I'll try to find you.
Jake: 我按照定位找你吧
Jake: I'll find you according to the location.
Jake: 你到了对吧
Jake: You've arrived, right?
Shure:  所以你不能只拎一包湿巾了
Shure: So you can't just bring one pack of wet wipes.
Shure:  拜拜
Shure: Bye-bye.
Jake: 哎哎拜拜拜拜
Jake: Okay, okay, bye-bye.
Alice: 我们这能放下吗
Alice: Can we put it here?
Lucia: 同想问
Lucia: I was wondering the same.
Alice:可以吧
Alice: Should be fine, right?
Katrina: 放后备箱
Katrina: Put it in the trunk.
Jake: 好像说在那个地方
Jake: They said it's over there.
Jake: 你看你看是在
Jake: Look, look, is it there?
Shure:  咱们那个是什么来着
Shure: What's that thing again?
Alice: 嗯是这个门出去
Alice: Yeah, it's this door.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Alice: 我们刚刚下车的地
Alice: The place where we just got off.
Katrina:  我们俩一起
Katrina: The two of us together.
Jake: 那你帮我导个航
Jake: Can you navigate for me?
Jake: 好谢谢你
Jake: Thanks a lot.
Katrina:  哎我好害怕这人
Katrina: Hey, I'm really scared of this person.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 哎呦
Jake: Oh dear.
Katrina:  哇这一包这么重
Katrina: Wow, this bag is so heavy.
Katrina: 他刚刚拎的
Katrina: He just carried it.
Lucia: 没有那袋重
Lucia: It's not as heavy as that bag.
Tasha: 我说真的
Tasha: I'm serious.
Katrina:  因为我买了两大瓶哎
Katrina: Because I bought two large bottles.
Lucia: 嗯谢谢谢谢
Katrina: Yeah, thanks, thanks.
Jake: 这个很重要这个很重要这个
Jake: This is very important, very important.
Jake: 这个哎可以谢谢谢谢
Jake: This, oh, okay, thanks, thanks.
Alice:好了不用走了就在这
Alice: Alright, no need to move, just stay here.
Katrina:  他能进来吗
Katrina: Can he come in?
Alice: 是呢
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 他能进来啊
Jake: He can come in?
Jake: 这么厉害
Jake: That's impressive.
Katrina:  我就把这个放下了啊
Katrina: I'll just put this down here, okay?
Jake: 今天挺暖和的
Jake: It's quite warm today.
Jake: 一点也不冷
Jake: Not cold at all.
Katrina:  新加坡一般多少度啊
Katrina: What's the usual temperature in Singapore?
Jake: 呃 23-31每天
Jake: Uh, 23-31 every day.
Katrina:  这么热一年四季都是吗
Katrina: Is it this hot all year round?
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: It's the same every day.
Tasha: 这么热嗯
Tasha: It's this hot, huh?
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: It's the same every day.
Jake: 是挺闷的
Jake: It's quite stuffy.
Jake: 但是现在我适应了
Jake: But now I'm used to it.
Jake: 我觉得还好
Jake: I think it's okay.
Jake: 只要中午不出去都还好
Jake: As long as you don't go out at noon, it's fine.
Tasha: 哇你看这个大葱头
Tasha: Wow, look at this big scallion.
Lucia: 你们是四季如夏吗
Lucia: Is it summer all year round for you?
Tasha: 上下两层都是这样子的
Tasha: Both floors are like this.
Jake: 对是不是每天都一样
Jake: Yeah, isn't it the same every day?
Alice:我是不是得
Alice: Should I...
Jake: 赤道2度北纬2度
Jake: 2 degrees north of the equator.
Lucia: 真的好热听起来
Lucia: It sounds really hot.
Lucia: 你知不知道
Lucia: Do you know that?
Alice:往那再走一点点
Alice: Move a little further.
Katrina: 路边是不是应该进不来吧
Katrina: He probably can't come in, right?
Tasha: 他不能进来吗
Tasha: Can he come in?
Jake: 到了吗
Jake: Is he here?
Alice:不知道能不能过去
Alice: I don't know if he can get through.
Tasha: 让他打电话问他一下吧
Tasha: Let him call and ask.
Jake: 我这个电话我这欠费了
Jake: My phone is out of credit.
Jake: 打不出去
Jake: I can't make calls.
Jake: 咱们下课里面是啥
Jake: What's our next class?
Jake: 他是什么色的
Jake: What color is it?
Alice:他好像停了
Alice: I think he stopped.
Alice:别克GL8
Alice: It's a Buick GL8.
Lucia: 棕色棕色的别克我意思
Lucia: A brown Buick, I mean.
Jake: 他是要我们走过去吧
Jake: Does he want us to walk over?
Alice:我们应该往前走一点点吧
Alice: We should move forward a bit.
Jake: 那我们走吧
Jake: Then let's go.
Lucia: 走哎
Jake: Let's go, hey.
Jake: 我刚刚拿的是这个吗
Jake: Did I just take this?
Alice: 球友们刚下车的地方
Alice: Friends, it's where we just got off.
Jake: 这是地铁吗
Jake: Is this the subway?
Alice: 喂您好
Alice: Hello?
Jake: 最前面这一条
Jake: The first line at the front.
Jake: 天上这一条
Jake: The one in the sky.
Lucia: 是的那呃
Lucia: Yes, um...
Alice:呃暂时还没有
Alice: Uh, not yet.
Jake: 1号线哎
Jake: Line 1, hey.
Jake: 是1号线吗
Jake: Is it Line 1?
Jake: 几号线
Jake: Which line?
Katrina: 咱走这出去吧
Katrina: Let's go out this way.
Alice:永和大王
Alice: Yonghe King.
Jake: 奔驰啊是吗呵呵呵
Jake: Mercedes, huh?
Alice: 永和大王门口
Alice: In front of Yonghe King.
Lucia: 永和大王那个吗
Lucia: The one at Yonghe King?
Tasha: 门口
Tasha: At the entrance.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice:是是那个吗
Alice: Is it that one?
Alice: 我靠哎呀
Alice: Whoa, oh my gosh.
Alice:双闪的
Alice: It's got hazard lights on.
Katrina: 啥颜色
Katrina: What color?
Alice:看到有双闪
Alice: I see hazard lights.
Lucia: 哪有哪有哪有打双闪啊
Lucia: Where, where, where are the hazard lights?
Alice: 咋是不是那个呀
Alice: Is that the one?
Jake: 啊我看到了
Jake: Ah, I see it.
Jake: 对对对确实
Jake: Yes, yes, definitely.
Alice:我是不是得绕一下
Alice: Should I go around?
Jake: 呃就那边吧
Jake: Uh, just over there.
Jake: 不用绕
Jake: No need to go around.
Alice: 那个那个我们这能出去吧
Alice: Can we go out from here?
Katrina: 我们去
Katrina: We're going.
Tasha: 我先过
Tasha: I'll go first.
Alice:呃好的
Alice: Uh, okay.
Alice:我看见您了
Alice: I see you.
Alice:您是那个FA 503是吧
Alice: You are FA 503, right?
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Ah.
Alice:好的我们找到了谢谢
Alice: Okay, we found it, thank you.
Lucia: 这个我们是不是可以放后备箱
Lucia: Can we put this in the trunk?
Jake: fa
Jake: FA.
Lucia: 或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that.
Alice: 后备箱可以打开吗
Alice: Can the trunk be opened?
Tasha: 啊天呐咦
Tasha: Oh my gosh, wow.
Alice:有点小
Alice: It's a bit small.
Katrina: 够还是够
Katrina: It's enough.
Alice:挤一下吧
Alice: Let's squeeze it in.
Alice:再来一个
Alice: Let's do another one.
Katrina:  鸡蛋我抱着吧
Katrina: I'll hold the eggs.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Katrina:  这不还和鸡蛋放哪了
Katrina: But where should we put the eggs?
Jake: 谢谢哎呀哎呦
Jake: Thanks, ouch, ouch.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Katrina:  哎呦哎呦
Katrina: Ouch, ouch.
Katrina:  疼
Katrina: It hurts.
Jake: 好疼
Jake: It really hurts.
Alice:还空出来一个位
Alice: There's still a spot left.
Alice:要不然搁前边吧
Alice: How about we put it in the front?
Katrina:  放放我身上也行
Katrina: You can put it on me too.
Katrina:  这后面只有两个人
Katrina: There are only two people in the back.
Jake: 就放那边吧
Jake: Just put it over there.
Jake: 放那边可以吧
Jake: Put it there, okay?
Jake: 还是放哎呦
Jake: Or put it... ouch.
Jake: 看一眼
Jake: Take a look.
Jake: 好疼好疼啊
Jake: It really hurts, it really hurts.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵摸摸头
Jake: Hahaha, pat my head.
Jake: 摸摸头
Jake: Pat my head.
Jake: 哎不用不用不用
Jake: No, no, no, no need.
Lucia: 唉他是自己的
Lucia: Oh, it's his own.
Jake: 它自动的它自动的它自动的自动的
Jake: It's automatic, it's automatic, it's automatic.
Alice:好的给你的
Alice: Okay, it's for you.
Jake: 摁了他就以为我们要干什么
Jake: If you press it, they think we're doing something.
Alice:我们俩坐后边吧
Alice: Let's sit in the back.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Sure.
Tasha: 啊怎么还订6座呢
Tasha: Why did they book six seats?
Jake: 那应该点几座
Jake: How many should we book?
Katrina:  那我坐老板位了
Katrina: Then I'll sit in the boss's seat.
Lucia: 那我还坐前面吧
Lucia: Then I'll still sit in the front.
Lucia: 如果没有人晕车的话
Lucia: If no one gets carsick.
Alice:来吧baby
Alice: Come on, baby.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Ouch.
Tasha: 好疼
Tasha: It hurts.
Lucia: 哎这个能往后一点吗这怎么弄
Lucia: Can this go back a bit? How does this work?
Lucia: 啊不我是说这个啊对靠背
Lucia: Oh no, I mean this, yeah, the backrest.
Alice:现在还要录吗
Alice: Are we still recording?
Jake: 这个关了吧不
Jake: Let's turn it off, no.
Jake: 不用录了
Jake: No need to record anymore.
Tasha: 呃现在就关了
Tasha: Uh, turn it off now?
Jake: 现在关了
Jake: Turn it off now.
Jake: 可以这一段
Jake: This part is fine.
Jake: 这一段主要没有go Pro
Jake: This part mainly doesn't have the GoPro.
Jake: 你每次go Pro贼麻烦
Jake: Every time with the GoPro, it's super troublesome.
Alice:又把我家地址录上去
Alice: You recorded my home address again.
Katrina:  中指是吗
Katrina: The middle finger, right?
Katrina:  行
Katrina: Okay.